[Music]
welcome back to people in our sense it's
a dangerous time to be comedian dave
chappelle was attacked on stage this
month after christmas trend jokes and of
course we had the will smith chris rock
smackdown at the oscars now some stand
up to question whether it's even safe to
perform or joining me now is comedian
howie mandel a former teammate of mine
on america's got talent and although
he's very funny and although i really
like him he can also be incredibly
annoying as this clip from our time
together on agt will show you
thank you
go away
seriously give any juice or soda i think
some of them might be a little parched
have a drink
can you get out of my dressing room
please
can you get out of my dressing room
please
i'm joined by harry mandel i'll never
forgive you for some of the stuff you
did to me on that show i'm still so
traumatized
nobody no there is nobody in the world
that i enjoy annoying more than you
young man and you know
and and first of all congratulations on
this show thank you i've been reading
i've been watching it yesterday the
headlines were all over the place here
in america that appears morgan was
called the c word
live on
and i can't figure out maybe it's the
the ocean between us what's wrong with
being canadian yeah
actually it was a four-letter word
beginning with c cool you wouldn't know
anything about it but it was uh it was
great harry oddly i've actually missed
you and i'd be worried about you
genuinely because you are a very
well-known public germaphobe you
absolutely hate germs you you were
fist-bumping people way before it became
kobe cool uh how have you d how have you
dealt seriously with a pandemic how's it
been for you
it has been absolutely horrible i have
moved my therapist into a whole new tax
bracket uh i've upped my medication you
know there was always some comfort in
having people around who weren't as
neurotic as i was to go howie don't
worry about it i've watched no one is
sick here and now uh there's nobody to
say that and you know misery does not
enjoy company so this has been hor it's
been horrible for the whole world but um
i'm having a hard time dealing with it
and have you have you on top of that
have you had covert
yeah yeah i got kovit because the lovely
people as we mentioned we work together
in iraq oh i'm sorry agt what a slip-up
i uh it felt like iraq honestly working
with you but anyway
we won the kids choice award this year
and they made me go
to accept it with my fellow castmates
with simon and everybody and i a lot of
people i don't know do you get the kids
choice awards in in the uk no you know
the nickelodeon
they find people they slime that's a big
thing they drop slime on them i did not
get slime went viral i caught the uh the
kovid and was locked away for about 10
days after that but you were okay after
it
i don't know that i'm ever okay but i'm
fine yeah that would be that would be my
assessment of you as well i want to talk
about uh comedy harry because it seems
like comedy is under attack both from
cancel culture where you can't tell
jokes anymore like you used to but also
physical attack you know we saw what
happened at the oscars with will smith
and chris rock and then
and then dave chappelle weeks later
being attacked literally by somebody
from the audience what do you make of it
how's it made you feel about being a top
stand-up in america
i would like to be funny and witty at
the moment but i got to tell you that
this has been i i feel it in the gut you
know for me standup comedy was my
respite at the end of the day when we do
shows like agt or or any other show that
i've done or [ __ ] now on netflix
there are certain confines that i have
to work in and
stand-up comedy was and i was inspired
in the 70s by watching richard pryor
live on stage put together which became
i believe the seminal comedy movie of
all time and and that's live on the
sunset strip who this probably inspired
people like eddie murphy and dave
chappelle
the the the the art form of free speech
in in comedy was this was the place
where you could just there were no
boundaries there were no limits there
was nothing that is too soon there was
nothing politically incorrect
especially in comedy and even in real
life if you offended somebody and and
they turned around and they were
offended if you said i'm only kidding
that kind of made it okay there's no
kidding anymore right and it is an art
form i have lost the fervor for
personally because i'm scared you know
my biggest fear
originally was that nobody would laugh
and it would be quiet then it was maybe
offending somebody and having them uh
you know approach me before a show then
it was the cancel culture you know
friends like gilbert godfrey who i have
a lot of friends who have lost entire
careers and comments because of it and
now after the oscars i think you know uh
violence begets violence you know here
in america we have mass shootings a mass
shooting doesn't happen in one
there we've been followed in this last
month by three mass shootings because
these are triggers and i'm afraid i'm
not enjoying being on stage like i was
that's really sad to hear um no i i do i
feel because i know how much you love it
i know i'm actually love performing with
an audience you're hilariously funny
when you're not annoying me in fact
probably particularly when you're
annoying me so it's sad to hear you say
that i mean i had ironically i was sort
of temporarily cancelled by one of your
old co-workers last year uh meghan
markle who used to be when you did deal
or no deal she was one of the suitcase
girls
she is sitting right behind me
for those that don't know me in your
country i'm like no like a bald knoll
edmond
aren't i
what are your what are your memories
what are your memories of miss markle as
a suitcase girl
i'm going to be totally honest with you
i had absolutely no memory of her i did
not remember until she was uh dating
harry and people started saying what can
you tell us about megan and i would say
who is megan and i didn't know i didn't
remember i i did not know her and i
don't remember her to this day
but maybe that's the the beauty of i
love that maybe she was happy
yes since you can't remember let's
forget about it before
you go very quickly have you been
invited yet to simon carl's wedding and
are you anticipating getting an
invitation if you haven't
i have not been invited have you not yet
i'm waiting
okay so i'll carpool with you and i'd
like to put my name on the card of
whatever gift it is that you purchased
them what do you get
not a bike
did you prefer did you prefer having me
sitting next to america's got talent or
simon
what do you want me to say me i'm on a
show on netflix now called [ __ ] and
i'm going to show you how it's played
right in that case
i've never loved anybody as much as i
loved working with you thank you thank
you
finally it's on the record harry great
to talk to you uh really is always a
pleasure mate thank you very much
all the best take care
love harry
you